>>> TIME NOW FOR THE RIDICULOUS.
IF YOU'RE NOT IN THE DALLAS AREA
YOU WERE MISSING OUT ON A
SPECTACULAR MORNING SHOW CALLED
"THE BROADCAST."
LAST WEEK THEY VEERED WAY FROM
SPRINGTIME PIZZA AND HOW TO SLIM
IN ON YOUR FAT PETS TO WEIGH IN
ON THIS.
MICHAEL SAM KISSING HIS
BOYFRIEND.
NOW TO SAY THAT THIS BITTERLY
DIVIDED THE ALL-IMPORTANT
DEMOGRAPHIC OF LADIES IN DALLAS
KNOCK OFF OF THE VIEW IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
>> WHY AM I NOT ALLOWED THE SAY
IT OFFENDS YOU.
>> IT COMES OFF AS BEING RACIST
TOWARDS HOMOSEXUALS.
>> RACE.
>> THIS IS THE PROBLEM.
>> YOU CAN'T SAY WHAT YOU FEEL
WITHOUT BEING PERSECUTED.
IF IT DOESN'T GO ALONG WITH
MAINSTREAM.
>> THERE'S MORE.
IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE PLAYING
PREDICTABLE EXCUSE, GET READY TO
MARK SOME BOXES.
>> IN A MOMENT OF CELEBRATION
FOR SOMETHING VERY EXCITING TO
HAPPEN TO HIM BECAUSE HE WORKED
HIS BUTT OFF AND NOW WE'RE
BEATING HIM UP --
>> I DON'T CALL IT A MOMENT OF
CELEBRATION.
>> ATTACKING PEOPLE --
>> HERE'S THE THING.
>> HOLD UP.
WHY AREN'T YOU CALLING THAT A
MOVEMENT CELEBRATION.
YOU DIDN'T FEEL THAT WAS A
MOMENT OF CELEBRATION.
>> NO.
HERE'S THE THING.
IT'S BEING PUSHED IN FACES.
>> KISSING HIS WIFE --
>> I WOULD HAVE SAID GET A ROOM.
MY TURN.
HERE'S THE THING, ESPN WOULD NOT
HAVE AIRED ANY OF IT HAD HE BEEN
KISSING HIS WIFE.
>> THIS WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE NEWS.
>> NO, I THINK WE ARE MAKING A
MOUNTAIN OUT OF A MOLE HILL.
>> THIS WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE NEWS.
>> I AGREE.
>> PERIOD.
>> THE ONE WHO IS AIR QUOTE
UPSET GOT SO FLUSTERED SHE ENDED
UP STORMING OFF THE SET BUT NOT
BEFORE SHE GOT IN SOME MORE
HOMOPHOBIC POINTS.
>> WHEN PARENTS DON'T HAVE A
CHOICE WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT
THEIR CHILDREN TO SEE THIS.
>> AMY THAT'S BEEN TAKEN
CRITICISM.
SHE HAS EVERY RIGHT TO EXPRESS
HER OPINION.
SHE WANTS US TO THINK OF THE
CHILDREN AND SHE HAS A POINT.
IF WE DON'T TAKE ACTION TV COULD
BECOME A FREE FOR ALL REPLETE
WITH HALF NAKED MEN AND
INDISCRIMINATE KISSING.
>> TICKET ARE STILL AVAILABLE.
YOU CAN TAKE HOME A CALENDAR.
STAY TUNED.
>> OKAY.
SHE WAS KISSING STRIPPERS AND
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THEM.
IT'S NOT LIKE TWO GUYS WHO ARE
IN LOVE OR ANYTHING.
LOOK, I GET A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY AGREEING WITH HER
AND THAT'S THEIR PREROGATIVE.
IT WILL TAKE TIME.
NEARLY HALF OF THOSE SURVEYED
THOUGHT IT WAS INAPPROPRIATE FOR
NETWORKS TO SHOW THE MICHAEL SAM
KISS.
TO AMY'S ARGUMENT NOBODY SHOWS
FOOTBALL PLAYERS KISSING THEIR
WIVES OR GIRLFRIENDS THAT'S NOT
TRUE AND I DON'T THINK SHE'S
BEING HONEST WHEN SHE WOULDN'T
WANT TO SEE THAT EITHER OR GET A
ROOM.
UNCOMFORTABLE SEEING SOME KIND
OF AFFECTION WHY